ambiance détendue lors de l'événement
verifone au parc sportif philippe
cousteau à la verrière lancé à la mi
juillet le rendez vous estival propose
des dizaines d'animations ludiques et
des points de restauration une opération
destinée aux familles de la ville et des
alentours est super
là c'est la deuxième fois que je viens
cette semaine et j'aime trop j'ai avec
mon fils et
ça se voit qu'on se plaît il est juste
derrière moi bassékou pige à un musée
avec mon copain voilà je viens vers
15h30 et je repars vers verifone n'est
pas une nouveauté pour la commune la
ville de la verrière a l'habitude
d'organiser ce type d'animations
estivales
mais cette année pour la première fois
l'événement se déroule sur un lieu
unique et sur une période étendue d'un
mois pendant l'été écoutez avec le co
vie de beaucoup de familles ne peuvent
pas partir en vacances
donc on a beaucoup de familles
algéroises qui sont restés dans la ville
est donc l'objectif de cet événement
c'est de proposer des animations pour
rendre l'était plus animé plus vivants
pour toutes les familles notamment
celles qui peuvent pas partir en
vacances à l'étranger ou en province
l'événement se terminera à la mi août et
devrait attirer plusieurs milliers de
visiteurs
vu le succès rencontré cette année la
ville de la verrière songe à organiser
une nouvelle édition en 2021 sur le même
concept que cette année